à doha je me tourne vers vous maintenant
on le disait 9 mai jour de la victoire
en russie c'est bien ça exactement
diène pas védié le jour de la victoire
comme chaque année depuis 1945 la russie
donc célèbre le 9 mai la victoire sa
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie un
véritable moment de communion c'est une
journée sacrée a placé sous le signe de
l'unité de la fraternité du patriotisme
également une fête sacrée qui a une
dimension particulière ici en russie
mais également pour tous les pays mais
aussi au pays en tout cas de l'union
soviétique car il faut le rappeler un la
seconde guerre mondiale et plus
précisément la grande guerre patriotique
le conflit qui a opposé l'allemagne à
l'urss entre le 22 juin 1941 et le 9 mai
45 est l'événement le plus important le
plus glorieux mais également le plus
terrible de l'histoire de la russie car
l'urss à l'époque et bien a payé un
lourd tribut plus de 27 millions de
victimes des femmes des soldats des
civils
enfin vraiment une grande partie de la
de la population à garder ses stigmates
de cette guerre il n'y a pas une famille
qui n'a pas été touchée par la guerre de
près ou de loin
et d'ailleurs il faut savoir que c'est
en grande partie grâce à l'engagement de
l'urss auprès des alliés pendant cette
guerre pendant cette seconde guerre
mondiale que finalement et bien
l'allemagne a capitulé peut-être que
sans voix lasse et ses forces russes
sur le fond on aurait pas aujourd'hui
ces commémorations en tout cas c'est
l'occasion aujourd'hui de rendre hommage
à ses vétérans à ses anciens combattants
ac est rond puisque ce sont des
véritables héros en tout cas ici en
russie
alors il faut savoir qu'au delà du
devoir de mémoire un petit peu populaire
c'est aussi un sentiment de fierté et de
joie que l'on ressent en russie ont
d'ailleurs on l'a senti dès notre
arrivée à l'aéroport dans les rues de
moscou il ya des drapeaux un petit peu
partout rouge avec le 9 mai inscrit dans
la rue également dans les grandes
artères de la ville il ya des écrans qui
diffusent des messages des témoignages
des anciens combattants le métro de
moscou célèbre métro de moscou
lui aussi commémore à sa manière le jour
de la victoire avec des rames de métro
qui ont été décorés avec des effigies de
grands maréchaux soviétique
bref partout la ville donc célèbre ce 9
mai et puis il ya aussi ce petit ruban
que vous portez pierre que je porte
aussi un qui ne sait pas encore envolé
évidemment c'est le rubans de
saint-georges orange ornée de trois
arrêts du renoir alors cessé des
couleurs symboliques qui représente en
fait qui représente le feu et la poudre
ils proviennent probablement du blason
de l'empiré russe qui était composé d'un
nom d'un aigle noir sur un champs d'or
et qui a été instaurée par catherine ii
afin de récompenser les les soldats
aujourd'hui tous les russes partout
porte ce petit ruban un vraiment voilà
un petit hommage à ses vétérans donc je
vous le voulez une journée à très
important de bien plus important que la
fête nationale alors vous savez le 14
juillet en france la fête nationale
c'est l'occasion de nouveau
voir un défilé militaire ici aussi on a
le droit à ce prestigieux défilé un
militaire beaucoup et d'ailleurs voir
derrière moi les soldats qui ce qui
s'apprête un défilé dans un peu moins
d'une heure
on va d'ailleurs tu étais un petit peu
le le pouls de cette place rouge à on
retrouve mona qui est au coeur de
l'événement
toronto l'attaquant corse est là
en effet laura c'est ici qu'ont fait le
66e anniversaire de la victoire ici sur
une passion une place emblématique à
moscou qui veut littéralement dire
l'appel place alors en russe elle se dit
que l'as maya clochette et j'espère que
je le prends dans ce bien et je peux
vous dire que vu ici on en prend plein
la vue il y a eu à quelques instants
encore les dernières répétitions de
quelques défilés des femmes et des
hommes et qui défilait à ma gauche et à
ma droite alors pour ce défilé on attend
plus de douze mille militaires hommes et
femmes et plus de 190 véhicules et
matériels qui défileront ici sur cette
emblématique 1 place rouge une place
rouge qui vous l'avez vu peut-être est
fermée au public depuis plusieurs jours
les routes sont également fermés pour y
accéder et seuls les journalistes et les
invités d'honneur peuvent y accéder
plusieurs contrôles sont évidemment
nécessaires pour venir sur cette place
rouge alors vous vous en doutez c'est un
événement qui est préparé à la seconde
près plusieurs répétitions ces derniers
jours la première date du 29 avril il ya
eu celle du 4 mai et du 7 mai un défilé
que pourront suivre les russes en direct
à la télévision puis on le dit depuis ce
matin c'est un défilé qui est
extrêmement suivi très important pour
elle est russe et une phrase que j'ai lu
plusieurs fois sur les réseaux sociaux
dès ce matin le 9 mai est le jour le
plus important en russie c'est pour vous
dire à quel point cet événement est
attendu et il est regardé par et les
russes alors le président russe vladimir
poutine est attendu pour son
traditionnel discours et puis le défilé
militaire pourra commencer pour
l'instant c'est pas exactement quels
dirigeants vont être ici sur cette place
rouge ils seront sur la tribu
qui est juste à ma droite ici en blanc
pour l'instant le seul qui a confirmé sa
présence et le président du tadjikistan
voilà un grand dispositif pan tous les
hommes sont prêts en tout cas les
journalistes sont présents mais attendre
bien évidemment l'arrivée du président
russe vladimir poutine et on va
justement voir aussi ce qu'il en est du
côté de cet armement militaire puisqu'il
est énormément de véhicules aussi qui
vont défiler ici on retrouve verhaeghe
goffman verraes que du côté voilà des
chars et des blindés est ce que tout est
prêt également
oh oui devra tout est prêt nous sommes
sur la rue tverskaïa qui arrive
justement sur la place rouge où se
trouve justement mona toutes les unités
militaires sont prêtes une les
militaires sont prêts il ya les drapeaux
qui ont été déroulés sur sur les charges
sur les blondes et les deux drapeaux
d'époque parfois donc tout est prêt les
militaires se sont bien entraînés pour
faire ce défilé militaire elle malgré la
pluie qui commence
on va où ça va se passer de toute façon
la partie terrestre
j'en suis sûre pour la partie aérienne
on n'est pas 100% sur nous on le sera
peut-être à quelques minutes avant le
début de la partie terrestre ou ya déjà
eu un précédent paraît quand la partie
aérienne a dû être annulée à cause des
conditions météorologiques
mais cette année on espère quand même
que les avions vont passer par déchu la
place rouge en faisant un beau drapeau
tricolore russe
alors l'année dernière le dessiner on se
souvient avait été reporté à cause de la
pandémie de convives 19 cette année
aussi la pandémie est présente mais il
ya voilà d'autres mesures qui ont été
prises d'ailleurs des mesures anti
convient très importante cette année ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un pouce
verra oui bien sûr tous les journalistes
ont dû présenter soit un certificat de
vaccination soit un test sert négatif
pour justement couvrir ces événements et
surtout être aux côtés et des militaires
dans les véhicules ou couvrir à côté de
leurs justement sur la place rouge est
également le ministère de la défense
nous assure que tous les militaires qui
participent pour participer sur le
défilé dans le défilé sur la place rouge
et ils ont dû être vaccinés mais c'était
évidemment aux bénévoles est donc
vraiment on va voir pour les militaires
on n'a pas vu les masques parce que ils
ont ils ont tous été vaccinés
et voilà on va voir comment ça va se
passer sur la place rouge quand même
on va voir évidemment comment ça se
passait comme vous venez de dire
verhaeghe hoffman en tout cas on a tous
très hâte un devoir ce ce prestigieux
défilé c'est un moment unique qui est
assumé par des millions et des millions
de téléspectateurs chaque année car
contrairement peut-être à la france
voilà c'est en france on peut assister
être là présent regarder justement mes
défilés du 14 juillet alors ici non pour
des raisons de sécurité bien évidemment
ce n'est pas possible ce sont juste les
invités qui sont placés en tribune
d'ailleurs toute la ville de moscou -
est bloqué depuis à 5h ce matin on peut
pas circuler dans la ville et on attend
donc un dc3 quart d'heure le début de ce
défi n'est que vous allez pouvoir suivre
en direct sur arte france en compagnie
notamment de pierre merci beaucoup
d'aura belle rasic en direct de à moscou
merci également à verhaeghe hoffman et à
monaco dès lors qu'ils sont sur le
terrain d'oran le voit derrière vous un
la place rouge qui commence à se remplir
de plus en plus de tous ces militaires
qui vont défiler dans maintenant un
petit peu plus dans un peu moins d'une
heure on vous envie de rats pour cette
vue peut-être un petit peu moins pour le
temps il fait que 6 degrés à moscou il
commence à pleuvoir
selon verhaeghe of male rentrée donc
vous réchauffer on a besoin de vous
aujourd'hui